well it's quite an honor to be kicking
off this session and I'm sure I will say
many things that are incredibly
objectionable or annoying or something
to many of you in this room and that's
why we're gonna leave time for Q&A so I
understand Dan Toby was telling me that
there was a discussion of a letter that
my husband Mitch Kate bore and I wrote
to her in the class how many of you were
part of that conversation
not many okay so but all questions are
permissible doesn't mean I'll answer
them but all questions are permissible
so I want to talk about where it is this
there we go I want to talk about the
current situation in the tech ecosystem
this is Ryan Craig who's managing
partner of what used to be known as
university ventures and recently changed
their name and he says those of us under
age 50 have known nothing but a bull
market in inequality a little bit wake
you up make you think and our next quote
nope
there our next quote genius is evenly
distributed by zip code opportunity is
not so that drives a lot of what we do
at Cape or capital and the other
organizations that I'll be talking about
briefly get our clicker going here get
those themes back there they are so I
want to talk about a few things here
when I talk about our current climate
what we're seeing in tech especially in
employee activism in CEO activism
hashtag me too how that's come into the
tech ecosystem challenges access and
inequality a question being raised very
recently who is indeed self-made is this
country is any educational institution
including the one where we are now
a real meritocracy and why or why not
want to talk about a leaky tech pipeline
there's lots of debate on is there or is
there not a pipeline problem talk a
little bit about a study we did about
who leaves tech and why then I'm gonna
go into Cape or capital our investment
criteria our founders commitment who we
are
a little bit about who's in our
portfolio and why I'm incredibly hopeful
pot companies is not what you think
although we did our first cannabis
investment recently pot companies people
ops tech we have this will be the fifth
year we're running a people ops tech
pitch competition looking at seed stage
tech startups that are leveraging that
technology to mitigate bias in all
aspects of sourcing hiring interviewing
promotion compensation performance
review succession planning and then
smash smash is a summer math and science
honors Academy program I co-founded 16
years ago has a chapter actually on this
very campus and then some ideas to
ponder as we move into questions so here
are some things that have been going on
in very recently in our tech ecosystem
we had 20,000 Google employees walk out
in November over responses to a sexual
harassment situation about a someone who
left with a 90 million dollar severance
packet and also more recently
challenging a board member for the AI
organization and 2,500 Googlers signed a
petition to get that person removed we
have a very new climate of employee
activism in tech I would not have
predicted that and it's popping up lots
of places this is the the new AI council
where the 2,500 employees just this is
within the last week demanding this
person not be present then you've got
CEO activism
you've got somebody saying I'm gonna
take a hit to my profits I'm not going
to sell guns anymore
you've got executives seeing positive
impact on their companies for taking
what they see as social values based
kind of stamped Nike in promoting Colin
Kaepernick took a bold clear stand on a
divisive issue and earned six billion
dollars in the process and we're seeing
both what are seen as blue and red
company CEOs are saying that they can't
sit on the sidelines so used to be that
our workplaces were a little bit of a
safe space from politics and now they're
sort of right there in the middle of it
which poses big questions for you as
engineers as leaders future leaders
about what stand do you take what kind
of company do you work for
so we've seen a lot going on hashtag me
too there's a new group actually our
foundation is one of the eleven
foundations that we've pooled 20 million
dollars to go support the on-the-ground
work of women organizing domestic
workers hotel workers you know across
farm workers tech workers Hollywood and
so we're seeing a lot going on in
individual workplaces in reaction to
hashtag me to those of you who've been
looking at it in the tech sector you
know that CEOs have lost their jobs like
Sophie because of harassment you know
that venture capitalists have been
kicked out of their firms firms have
imploded like binary so these are
current and troubling issues we've got
this either-or view of diversity and
inclusion and when in the tech ecosystem
and for any of you who are on Twitter
you'll see these debates about there is
a pipeline problem there isn't a
pipeline problem it's a tech culture
problem I think that's the wrong framing
whichever way you look at it I think
we've got a set of systemic biases and
that explained our pipeline problem and
that explained the ways in which tech
culture are not really inclusive to
everyone and we're not talking about
bigots we're not talking about intent
here we're talking about what has grown
up and the ways in which biases have
gotten filtered into our systems which
is what got the Googlers riled up about
AI because of the fierce about the bias
that gets built into AI we have
something going on now you may have seen
Kylie Jenner described as a self-made
millionaire billionaire and a lot of
people said what what is self-made about
what she's done she was you know born on
third base and she didn't hit a homerun
she might have gotten walked in and then
we see things that are actually
affecting this very campus with the
college admissions scandal so we're
trying to figure out what is a
meritocracy we can have the aspiration
to be a meritocracy there's some very
interesting rigorous research on that
second headline there meritocracy
doesn't exist and believing it does is
bad for you there's some really
interesting it's mostly out of the field
of social psychology about what happens
when companies put in meritocratic
processes there's a professor at Sloan
School at MIT who's written about the
paradox of meritocracy and what happens
when meritocracy is an explicit goal of
a company managers make less
meritocratic decisions because they
think somebody else is taking care of it
quite fascinating so here is an
interesting thing when we look at are we
self-made or not and this is is success
determined by luck and the percent who
answered yes by
income so the higher your income the
less likely you are to say that happened
by luck the more likely you are to say I
did that all by myself and the less
income you have the more you will say
luck is a huge factor there so I want to
walk you through a couple of composites
I have been working on College
Admissions I've been working on college
access programs for a few decades now
and I want to illustrate this issue
about the biases that underlie things
that get us to have a techie system that
looks like what we do so let's take a
couple of composite characters will call
them Brandon and Juanita and this is
while they're in k-12 education so
somebody's got high tech computer labs
in their school
somebody's got no science labs no
computer labs completely accidents of
zip code I don't know if anybody in this
room choose their parents anybody choose
the zip code in which you were born
that's what these issues that we're
wrestling with today are asking us to
think about it so when does the teacher
think you're gonna succeed we know
you're gonna go far when do you get
those messages of encouragement and when
do you have low teacher expectations
when does the teacher say mm I think
that's too many AP classes for you I
don't think you're Stanford material
that gets said every day to high school
students from low-income backgrounds so
going about how many AP classes are
taken I'm working with a bunch of
college admissions officers now to look
at we ought to be thinking about the
denominator of AP classes when we're
looking at college admissions if you
took three AP classes in high school and
you're up against somebody who took 27 I
want to know if you took all three of
the ones offered at your school and the
one who took 27 took half of it AP
classes it tells you gives you
whole different vantage point on those
students so we want to make sure that we
are indeed rewarding merit or
achievement not rewarding access or
privilege who's got after-school stem
programs who works after school whose
family hires them an SAT coach who can't
afford an SAT class do any college
admissions applications ask how many
times you took the SAT maybe we ought to
think about ways that we could actually
do that try to get move along here to
college go to a top 10 school go to
Community College so that you can save
money and live at home how do you pay
for school if your family if you're
lucky enough to have your family pay for
school which is wonderful it means you
can participate in lots of things it
means you can take a job at a startup if
you're graduated with six figures in
loans you're not going to be able to
afford a start-up salary so we right
away determine by birth who has access
to what kind of future who can afford an
unpaid internship only somebody who's
got somebody else to support them so
there are many folks that are now trying
to make unpaid internships illegal if
you will or not permissible who's got to
work part-time over the summer to put
food on their family's table who has a
role model there's a lot of fascinating
literature there's a professor bushu
dust Gupta at UMass Amherst who's done a
study for women of color any racial
minority woman if you have one professor
in four or five years that looks like
you it makes a statistically significant
difference in your major and your grade
point average so we ought to think about
just who is it that you're exposed to
as role models and how different that
makes the outcome who can hire a tutor
who can't even go to the free study
session because they've got to have a
work-study job and so we just forget
about all of these subtle barriers that
nobody put in anybody's way
intentionally nobody said aha let's make
it much harder for one NIDA than Brandon
but day-to-day life is indeed much
harder so let's look at what happens as
we go to the workplace who sends
recruiters to your college recruiters
don't go to community colleges who
submits resumes cold who taps a personal
Network who doesn't know anyway I'll
talk a little about our smash program
but most of our smash scholars from the
Bay Area don't know anyone who works in
tech that's pretty amazing
coming in via employee referral employee
referral is one of the most biased
hiring mechanisms that exists because in
this country we our friendships and and
there's a non-profit that's not a lot of
research on this all of us tend to have
friends who look like us whatever group
we are in which means if you've got a
perfectly diverse workplace an employee
referral system is great because it will
continue that if you don't have a
diverse company employee base and you
put an employee referral system in it's
actually just gonna replicate who's
still here so the same thing who feels
like they can the salary differences
we're getting a lot of attention paid to
pay equity these days who feels like
they can negotiate who gets punished if
they can negotiate who feels at home in
the workplace culture and who feels like
I don't really fit who gets promoted in
the first year and who becomes a lever
and that's what our tech lever study was
all about who leaves Tech and why
single greatest reason that women of
color leave tech is being passed over
for promotion for those who aren't quite
sure about is there a pipeline problem
or not let me just very quickly show you
AP computer science test takers by race
and ethnicity and so you've got the the
darker bars the k-12 population and the
lighter bar is AP Computer Science
participation so you can just see for
white for Asian and see the differences
by racial and ethnic group about who has
access to who takes AP Computer Science
so by looking at that we understand we
don't have a steady pipeline so if you
combine Hispanic Latino X black
african-american grand total is sixteen
percent so you can go through the same
whoops thing by gender there let's see
if I can get that back no it's there
it's thinking yeah gender
AP Computer Science test takers just
under one quarter are women that is the
pipeline problem what explains that is
the bias problem technical employees by
race at top tech companies large tech
companies in in particular venture back
founders by race and ethnicity lateen X
don't even get come up there
so pre k12 education this is about women
and girls of color in computing this is
a big collaborative of about 15
researchers that we are participating in
melinda gates --is pivotal ventures
group is participating in researchers
from across the country trying to figure
out how to get more girls and women of
all backgrounds into computing and
getting in tech and staying in tech
among all women employed in computer and
information science occupations only 12
percent are black or Latinas and you see
the tech companies spending a lot of
time and a lot of money trying to work
on diversity and not having the baseline
data to work from that's the in terms of
four percent of high school students
taking AP Computer Science two percent
were black girls less than one percent
were the Native American
there's the VC one eighty percent of new
small businesses are started by black
women and but they account for less than
four percent of the VC money so again
it's not about a lack of an
entrepreneurial appetite it's again an
access issue so the tech lever study
that I mentioned is that you can get you
just google it it's on the web for free
a couple of thousand engineers who
leaves tech and why it was done two
years ago for findings unfairness drives
turnover cost billions a year
experiences differ dramatically between
groups but specific initiatives can and
do make a difference if they're
formulated accurately so very quickly
hopefully each of those their unfairness
37% said that unfair treatment was the
most frequently cited reason for leaving
twice as many left because they felt
treated unfairly in their workplace as
were recruited away and that's across
all groups and the unfairness differs
40% men of color were most likely to
leave due to unfair treatment experience
has differed dramatically across those
groups and this includes things that are
not about race or about gender these
include things like bullying one in ten
women experienced unwanted sexual
attention which has as we talked about
been getting more attention thirty
percent of women of color passed over
for promotion single greatest reason
turnover sixteen billion dollars for
unfair treatment in employee replacement
costs annually and that's just the
turnover costs it's fairly standard ly
and conservatively accepted what is the
cost to replace a person so be cheaper
to fix it there we go and we also ask
the leavers what would have made you
stay and we ask them how their
experience impacts their willingness to
refer a friend a family member someone
else to that company so thirty five
percent slightly more than a third said
no based on my experience I can't
recommend that company as a place to
work nor can I recommend its products
and services so if you want to try to
calculate that cost that is one that is
not in the sixteen billion economists
don't agree on how to calculate that
kind of reputational hit but the good
news a comprehensive approach can in
does make a difference both in reducing
unfair treatment and in increasing
retention or reducing turnover so the
majority if you ask people what would
have kept you they have an answer the
majority would have stayed if they felt
like there was a place to go to get
their problem fixed right and we're not
talking about a formal complaint we're
not talking about a lawsuit we're
talking about practical problem solving
mechanisms where they feel like who they
can go to is impartial an impartial
third party for instance there were five
specific measures we tested for having a
head of diversity and inclusion doesn't
make a statistically significant
difference either in the amount of
unfairness or in the amount of turnover
second thing we hear all the ones we
tested for setting explicit diversity
goals and underrepresented employee
referral bonuses actually those two
independently make a statistically
significant difference conducting
unconscious bias training does not how
many have gone through an unconscious
bias training didn't make a difference
right we've wasted some time might have
been fun might have been interesting
doesn't make a statistically significant
difference in reducing unfairness or
increasing retention see if we can get
the last one up there employee resource
groups many companies virtually all tech
companies including young startups have
employee resource groups and indeed
those can be great ways to meet
colleagues compare notes on who's a good
manager how do you get promoted around
here but again doesn't make a
statistically significant difference
what does make a difference actually
besides these two individual kinds of
initiatives is all five together all
five make more of a difference than just
those two independently so I want to
switch to something else which is
do you create companies that take all
this information into account so I know
you're talking about social impact
companies you're talking about sparks
you're talking about sustainability
there's a prevailing view that social
impact is separate from economic value
and that investing in social enterprises
means is concessionary towards the
returns that you're giving those up we
actually don't think about that at Cape
or capital we think the other way to
think about it is that the overlap of
social impact and economic value you can
find that both are driven from the same
source so here our investment criteria
we have about a hundred and thirty
companies in our portfolio we're going
to be releasing our returns for the
first time ever on May 8th we do seed
stage tech startups the core business
not the philanthropic effort not the CSR
not a side effort the core business
closes gaps of access and/or opportunity
and/or outcome for low-income
communities and/or communities of color
we have not found any problem with deal
flow people were very worried about that
we had more than three thousand deals
come across our desks last year and we
invest in somewhere between 10 and 15 a
year in 2016 we became the first venture
capital firm to implement a founders
commitment that was January of 2016 we
don't write a check unless the CEO makes
a commitment to building a welcoming
culture and a diverse team we are not
prescriptive at all we say to our
founders depending on who your customers
are
we think that your aspiration should be
that your employee mix matches your
customer base and if you think about it
sounds like a good business practice so
if you're selling into public schools in
the u.s. k12 you're gonna have a very
different demographic than if you are a
FinTech company and you are a b2b
company and your clients are Wall Street
so all of this is on the website those
are some of our companies you might
recognize some names there so when we
ask them how to implement this we ask
them to look at four things and there's
a an acronym of give here set goals and
again they set their own goals we're not
we're not prescribing it we're asking
them to set goals that help them realize
their business goals we ask them to
invest in tools and resources and
training that are going to help them
mitigate bias in their product
development in their hiring that again
is just gonna make them a better
business we encourage them to volunteer
with either underrepresented communities
encourage their employees to or
especially to figure out how their
employees can volunteer with groups that
are representative of their customers of
their customer base part of basic
customer development and then the follow
is the final one is about educating
oneself as a CEO as a founder as well as
your workforce that is our team we will
tell you I will tell you in a minute
half of our partners are African
American not your standard VC issue 3/4
of our investment team come from
underrepresented backgrounds either
black or Latino
and another one here we're slightly more
than half women over half of our
investments have a founder who is a
woman and or a person from an
underrepresented background see what we
got here
it skipped it the last one said an
independent study something called
project Diane listed us as having
invested in there it is having invested
in more black women founders than any
other venture capital firm which is kind
of sad because we're small and it's not
just by percentage it is by absolute
number so I'm going to give you some
examples of three of our founders and
their and their businesses
that's Phaedra on the left Ellis
lampkins CEO of promise was a YC company
we were her first investor she is
looking at alternatives to cash bail
that's a very prevalent issue in our
criminal justice system debate right now
that's an issue criminal justice reform
is a bipartisan issue a majority of
Democrats and Republicans are supporting
massive criminal justice reform
including alternatives to cash bail the
overwhelming majority north of seventy
percent of people who are sitting in
county jails are there because they they
have not yet been arraigned and they
couldn't afford bail so what happens
while they're sitting there for a couple
weeks they lose their jobs if you lose
your job you're not paying your rent you
lose your home you lose your kids it is
and a significant number are there for
unpaid parking tickets there are just
these systemic ways in this society that
just are these snowball effects so
promise is working on many things
bringing some efficiency to the criminal
justice system inter interjecting some
tech in there what she's found traveling
around the country talking to places
right here in California
criminal justice system uses filemaker
pro i don't know if any of you even
remember filemaker pro people are
sitting in there waiting for their drug
test results and they can be waiting for
a couple of weeks because the systems
don't talk to each other and somebody
has to get the drug test result back on
a piece of paper and they have to re and
put it and then they print it out and
then they fax it to the jail all of this
could be done of course instantaneously
it could save taxpayers billions of
dollars and most importantly it could
save lives it could save livelihoods it
could save families so that's what
promise that's what Phaedra is all about
genius Plaza on Iruka Castro is the
founder she is currently serving more
than 15 million of the world's poorest
students children around the globe she
landed in Cambodia today she just texted
me she was in Africa last week her
platform is available in more than a
hundred languages including tribal
languages around the Amazon and tribal
languages in Africa she has a lot of non
deluded funding from places like the
World Bank to do things in in different
languages she is highly profitable while
doing amazing gap closing work her
company is based in Miami and she
literally has Sand Hill Road VCS hopping
in their private jets showing up on her
office saying I brought my checkbook and
I'm not leaving until I invest and she
says tell me about the diversity of your
partners I don't take money from VCS
that don't have a diverse partnership
when we've the honors aspiration is to
go public and I'm on her board and she's
got the revenues to do it this year
she's not gonna go out this year but
I'll tell you when all three of these
become household names and the other
dozens in our portfolio some different
firms will sit up and take notice
Danelle at block power is doing energy
retrofits in core urban community
buildings churches schools community
centers housing projects so he's new
york-based Anna is Miami based Phaedra
is oakland-based just three examples I
mentioned our people ops tech pitch
competition these are examples of some
of the companies in our portfolio that
are that are building companies using
tech to mitigate bias at scale and so
everything from compass which is a
fairly new investment on our part to
compensation
everything stock bonuses base pay
everything into one system because again
those are computer systems HR is running
something different than payroll is
running something different than
succession planning how do you do that
and how do you monitor for pay equity
the one above it tech bootable is a tech
enabled Ombuds way to get practical
neutral confidential problem-solving
advice smash I mentioned our summer math
and science honors Academy started 16
years ago Stanford was our second campus
Berkeley was our first campus these are
kids from public schools 40 50 60 %
dropout rates 16 years in we have a
hundred percent high school graduation
rate we have a hundred percent
acceptance to four-year colleges rate we
are twice the national average our kids
all underrepresented half girls since
day one our kids are pursuing stem
majors at twice the national average for
all students we're launching in Chicago
at the Illinois Institute
Chicago this year were and Carbondale
and we're opening at Northeastern in
Boston and trying to change tech some
ideas to ponder and some things to spark
your questions this is my last slide
here so what if we measured distance
travel instead of just finish lines what
if we could actually measure how far you
got on your own steam instead of how
many degrees
how many certificates how many points on
a test you got and wouldn't we find a
different kind of trait certainly where
I sit I understand that SAT scores and
GPAs are not predictors of successful
entrepreneurs right I'm looking for what
are those traits that predict successful
entrepreneurs we talked what I showed
you in the stories of Brandon and
Juanita is in essence really a leaky
tech pipeline where are all the places
that talent leaks out we've got more
than a million unfilled tech jobs right
now in this country and as we clamp down
on immigration we are slowing our own
GDP we are slowing our own innovation by
letting talent leak out of our homegrown
system what if we started measuring
capabilities
instead of pedigrees what if we looked
at and as we do on our investment
criteria
what's a gap closing company versus a
gap widening company a very prominent
local VC reached out to me about two
weeks ago now and said I have a company
I think you're interested in founded by
two women I said great tell me about it
organic baby food margins north of 50%
what's the business model affluent
families not going to touch it
that's gap
widening when you run a business that
promotes health disparities I don't want
to help you if you start a business that
promotes disparities in educational
outcomes I don't want to help you I want
people who want to close those gaps not
widen those gaps and again as we think
about this whether you're a founder an
aspiring founder an investor a limited
partner an employee and aspiring
employee at a tech startup I I will
assume that everybody in this room is
well-intentioned then if I asked you do
you want to make your co-workers life
miserable do you want to be you know you
want to exhibit bias towards your
colleagues every day you would say
absolutely not but what we need to start
focusing on is the impact it's not
enough to just be well intentioned we
got to look at the outcomes if we have
people leaving dropping out of the
pipeline dropping out a tech companies
dropping out as of the entrepreneurial
journey in such disproportionate numbers
I'm a researcher there's got to be a
reason and we need to figure out what it
is and so we're not accusing anybody of
anything we're saying let's look at the
impact let's look at who our educational
institutions and our workplaces
especially our startups are designed by
and for and see if we can fix that ok
time for questions those are some of our
smash dollars
you